Nos dicen que el radio de una esfera puede ser medido usando la fórmula
"r" igual a la raíz cúbica de "3v" entre 4pi,
donde "v" es el volumen.
Esto es interesante, usualmente te dan
el volumen como función del radio
y aquí es al revés, nos están dando el radio
como función del volumen.
Si el radio de la esfera es 6 pulgadas
entonces nos están dando el radio de 6 pulgadas,
nos están dando esto de aquí, el radio.
Si el radio es de 6 pulgadas,
¿cuál es su volumen?
Tenemos entonces 6 pulgadas,
todo está en pulgadas.
Esto es igual a la raíz cúbica...
la raíz cúbica de "3v",
tenemos que despejar "v" sobre 4pi.
Como primer paso nos deshacemos de la raíz cúbica,
elevando al cubo ambos lados.
Entonces tenemos
del lado izquierdo
6 elevado al cubo
y del lado derecho tenemos la raíz cúbica
de "3v" sobre 4pi, elevado al cubo.
Ahora, el lado izquierdo de esta igualdad
es 6 al cubo, eso es 6 por 6 = 36
por 6 es 180 más 36
216...
6 al cubo es igual a 216,
si el radio está en pulgadas,
al elevar al cubo esto es pulgadas cúbicas,
y esto es igual,
¿del lado derecho que tenemos?
tenemos que la raíz cúbica de "3v" entre 4pi...
estamos elevando al cubo...
aquí tenemos el exponente a la 1/3
multiplicado por 3, se hace un exponente 1,
por lo cual nos queda "3v" entre 4pi.
Bien para despejar "v" de esta ecuación,
la multiplicamos por el recíproco de su coeficiente, el recíproco de 3 entre 4pi es 4pi sobre 3,
multiplicamos ambos lados,
déjame asegurarme que lo puedas ver bien,
multiplicamos ambos lados por 4pi, sobre 3.
La razón por la cual estamos multiplicando por 4pi entre 3, es que se elimine con 3 entre 4pi.
Así es que aquí 4pi el numerador con 4pi el denominador se simplifica, se eliminan,
3 el numerador contra ese denominador se simplifica
y nos resulta entonces que "v" es igual a
4pi tercios por 216.
Esto lo puede escribir de la siguiente manera,
esto lo puede escribir como...
216 que multiplica...
deja ponerlo con el mismo color,
216 que multiplica a 4pi sobre 3.
Ahora 216, 2 más 1 = 3 más 6 = 9
ésta es la manera de ver si es múltiplo de 3,
al sumar los dígitos nos da un múltiplo de 3,
así es que si es divisible entre 3 vamos a simplificar,
216 entre 3, vamos a hacer la división,
216 entre 3, 21 entre 3 es a 7,
7 por 3 = 21
bajamos el 6,
entonces nos queda 6 entre 3 es 2,
2 por 3 = 6 menos 6 es igual a 0,
72.
216 entre 3 es igual a 72,
72 por 4pi es igual al volumen,
y esto está en pulgadas cúbicas,
así que 4 por 72
4 por 70 es 280,
4 por 2 es 8,
por lo que 4 por 72 es 288pi,
esto está en pulgadas cúbicas,
y ese es nuestro volumen.
Y así hemos terminado.